bonjour et merci prendre le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
vous avez donc passé 12 jours à
l'hôpital donc 36 heures en réanimation
comment vous portez-vous aujourd'hui
beaucoup tu es beaucoup mieux moi je
suis sûr qu'ils d'affaires pour moi tout
ça est derrière moi voilà j'ai surtout
une immense tristesse pour toutes celles
et ceux que j'ai croisés à l'hôpital ou
autour de moi qui malheureusement n'ont
pas eu la même chance que moi alors vous
avez bénéficié du traitement raul ce
traitement qu'il est très controversé
est ce que selon vous il faut toutefois
le généraliser parce que finalement
c'est une piste de guérison comme une
autre en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne je peux juste témoigner du fait
qu'en effet gelé appliquée je suis pas
un grand spécialiste du dossier
mais j'ai écouté je suis médecin je
connaissais les risques évidemment j'ai
pris les précautions nécessaires c'est à
dire un électrocardiogramme laquelle
yenni et puis j'ai pris exactement au
moment où on pouvait encore le faire sur
mon jeu tu me moi même de faire une
prescription après été avec un arrêté de
la interdite encadré en fait l'usagé
c'est assez incompréhensible d'ailleurs
pas score on a senti lisais je pense
éric saint trond sait capable de deux
d'assurer via leurs responsabilités et
que je peux juste témoigner que tous mes
collègues que j'ai connu ça n'a pas de
valeur statistique mais tous celles et
tous ceux que j'ai connus qui ont été
infectées l'ont également prix vont vous
dénoncez un manque totale d'anticipation
notamment concernant les masques de
protection il faudra demander des
comptes aux responsables dites vous
comment est-ce que vous travaillez dans
votre clinique avant d'être contaminés
comme six autres collègues médecins
comment la situation est gérée en
1 je crois que malheureusement j'ai
découvert qu' il y avait en effet une
pénurie un manque de préparation mecs et
manque de préparation n'est pas liée
elle est simplement l'établissement dans
lequel je travaillais que j'ai constatée
partout où je suis passé après que
c'était pareil un peu de façon
généralisée dans les ehpad évidemment
dans les cliniques dans les hôpitaux
même et y compris dans les très grands
thèmes plutôt tout le monde se bat en
fait pour avoir démasqué les moyens de
protection et c'est vrai que cette
pénurie qui qui qui a duré longtemps et
qui dure encore et dure encore autant de
semaines après le début de la crise
c'est proprement j'avais dire scandaleux
je sais pas si le mot est bien adaptée
mais il me semble que c'est le cas oui
alors moi j'ai pas valeur de
statistiques mon cas est un cas
particulier je sais pas comment ça se
passe comme ailleurs mais d'après ce que
je comprends je crois pas que je sois un
cas isolé
ce soit un cas au début j'étais très en
colère après le propre établissement
dans lequel j'étais mais en réalité j'ai
compris que c'était partout pareil et ça
ça renvoie la responsabilité à très haut
niveau me semble-t-il dans l'expérience
que nous avons accueilli vont en ce
moment vous vous restez en contact avec
vos collègues
le personnel soit 9 ce qu'il n'y a pas
eu d'amélioration ces dernières semaines
quant à la gestion de la crise dans les
hôpitaux il n'ya pas toulouse de masse
de meilleures protections qui bien sûr
je crois d'abord qu'il faut rendre un
grand hommage mais je vais désormais
recensés dans nos rangs mais douze jours
d'hospitalisation
j'ai pas le souvenir de visage puisque
je voyais que des yeux voyez des bases
que le foyer des visières jouer des
blues voyez les calottes rate est expert
dans les eaux remercie d'abord permettez
moi de dire parce qu'ils m'ont sorti
vraiment ce mauvais pas tous deux depuis
les soignants depuis la personne qui
venait faire le ménage dans la chambre
depuis depuis jusqu'aux médecins pendant
la porte un grand merci
oui je crois que quand même il ya une
amélioration chacun sait se débrouille
du mieux possible
les autorités vont quand même réagi mais
elles n'ont pas réagi à la hauteur
probablement me semble-t-il des enjeux
puis ça pose les vraies questions
d'organisation
peut-être un échelle oui vraiment
nationale voire même internationale on
est dépendant aujourd'hui c'est
probablement la leçon principale on est
indépendant alité en matière de nos
matériels des protections des plus
indispensables comme les masques le geiq
et respirateurs on est dépendants de
l'étranger et on voit bien dans une
crise comme ça quand on est pas maître
de ses stocks quand on n'est pas maître
de ses approvisionnements
elle y en de rares situations qu'on a
connu une situation de pénurie qui dure
encore qui s'améliore mais qui dure
encore et cette pénurie elle explique
peut-être aussi la stratégie de notre
pays a conduit c'est à dire que cette
stratégie liée aussi à la pénurie que
nous avions disputé au début que les
masques n'était pas tout à fait
nécessaire comme l'a expliqué que les
tests en ip ont comparé à des pays qui
se débrouillent beaucoup mieux et on
voit bien qu'il avait plus de matériel
et qu'ils se sortent mieux probablement
que nous de cette crise en tant que
maire cette fois ci que les échanges est
ce que vous avez avec les autorités
sanitaires notamment comment est ce que
vous voyez la gestion de cette crise est
ce que selon vous il faut généraliser le
port du masque multiplié les tests est
ce que un stade la responsabilité du
maire de l'état quel est votre ressenti
alors moi j'ai juste l'argentine mais
j'aurais juste dire que moi je suis pas
spécial pc de rien du tout derrière de
choc violent tuent un médecin de basse
voilà ce que je veux dire c'est cuit pas
le énième de spécialistes qui vient dire
voilà je le sais il faut faire ça ou ça
le bénéfice d'un an avec le recul on se
rend bien compte que le masque est un
indispensable par contre c'est une c'est
une réalité encore une fois j'en veux
beaucoup
un autre alain non pas à l'anticipation
parce que beaucoup de pays n'avait pas
anticipé donc peut-être ne pas être trop
critique à cet égard mais par contre
quand les choses se sont déclarés
vraiment nous expliquer à longueur de
journée que le traitement out est
inutile que parce que tout simplement
vous voulez pas le mettre en a beaucoup
que le masque était pas tu as tellement
utile
on se souvient de lui porte parole du
gouvernement qui venait nous dire sa
douleur ça c'est juste un essai juste
incroyable simplement avec le recul de
devoir donc moi je pense qu'en effet le
match est indispensable aujourd'hui plus
aucun ne fait aucun médecin que je
connaisse dans l'établissement où je
travaille et je travaille à auch
travaillera à nouveau dans quelques
jours et bien devenu travailler sans
masque évidemment cette étude
une évidence à la fois parce qu'on n'a
pas envie du nouveau contaminés ou
contaminés et on n'a pas envie de
contaminer nos patients donc ça me
semble être le bon sens évidemment merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions jean pierre
enjalbert médecin attendu qu'ovide 19
maire de saint-prix aussi et c'est dans
le val d'oise